弟）おそろ~
弟）ぁ～～はっはっｗｗｗ
はじめ）まじで？
はじめ）富山の実家に帰っております
はい
ま、年末っというとね、
実家に帰るんですよ。
今、弟がいます。
なんかねぇ
伝えよ！
弟）復っ・・・
復縁しました。
はじめ）どぉ～～～～
弟）ぁ～～～
はじめ）ま、年末なんで、そんなね
こう、大事なことが出来ないんで
まぁ、実家でゆる～くね、いこうと思うんですよ。
おい、俺のカード盗むな
というわけで、真後ろに弟がいるんですけど、
気にしないでください。
こちらの、富山ブラックサイダーというね、
黒いサイダーを見つけたわけですよ。
弟）わぁ～～～～～～～
はじめ）ｗｗｗ
弟）ｗｗｗｗｗ
はじめ）わぁ～～～～～～～って何？何？
なんか、俺のまねみたいな感じでしょ？
ブラックサイダー
えっ…飲みたいでしょ。でも正直。
濃いしょうゆ、こしょう多め、
黒スープが特徴のご当地ラーメン、富山ブラックの
やみつき感をイメージして作りました
ということで
ま、黒いサイダーでございます。
ちゃんと弟の分も買うっていう心優しい兄です。
弟）ありがとう。
はじめ）ｗｗ
よし、飲むぞ～
うぅ～
わわぁ～
はじめ）ｗｗｗ
実家だとマジで動画撮りにくいんだよ。
弟）しゃぁないね。
はじめ）尾崎豊の歌、歌いずらいっしょ？
裸で。
弟）え、余裕余裕余裕。
はじめ）じゃ、やれよ。
マジで、やれよ。
弟）ｗｗｗ
はじめ）やれよ、じゃぁ
今、下に親戚いるんですけど、
やれよ、絶対だよ。
裸で尾崎豊歌うんだよ。
それと同じ感じだよ、俺もねぇ
動画撮るのは尾崎豊の歌を裸で歌うようもんと変わんないからさぁ
飲んでみようと思います。
キャップ）・・・
はじめ）いただきますっ。
クンクンクン・・・
あっ、でもいい匂い
いただきますっ。(２回目）
ゴクゴクゴク…
あ～、マジか…これ・・・
まずいっすっ。
弟）ヘイ。ヘイ。
はじめ）いやっ、マジで。
うっ…ぁ
これ、ウソ…
ゴクゴクゴク…
後味、後味、後味…
２人）ｗｗｗｗｗｗ
はじめ）だめでしょ？
弟）えっこれはひどい。
はじめ）ちょっとだめでしょ。
ネタだねぇ。これ。
富山県、甘いなぁ…まだ
あっ、これはダメだぁ…
というわけで
１本余りました。
”＃＄％ありがとうございます。
おめでとうございます。
年末、みなさんどう過ごしますか？
ボクん家はなんかこう…年末年始は、
こう…家族とか、親戚とか、いとこが
集まるよね、めっちゃ。
うん。
めっちゃ集まるから、こう…
まぁ、一人暮らしみたいに好き勝手するわけにもいけないんで
僕は、そんな、こう…
家族の輪を乱す…たく（？）ないので
ま、家では普通の、いたって普通の男っすよ。
ねっ。
・・・・・・・・
弟）あっ///あっ///
はじめ）というわけで、年末です。
ホントに今年はお疲れ様でした。みなさん。
今日はね、まぁガキ使を観て
除夜の鐘を撞いてね
のんびり過ごそうと思います。
というわけでまた
２０１５年、来年もよろしくお願いします。
トゥディズはじめんズポイント
ぶるるるるるる”＃＄％＆’（）＝～
ババッン！
ゼロ～～～～
じゃぁな！
決まりました。ありがとうございます。
弟）ほんまにそれで出すん？
はじめ）カナ好きだよって言ってみ、最後。
カナ好きだよって
こういうところで言うと、喜んでくれるんだよ
弟）カナ、好きだよ（照）
はじめ）オ”ェェェェェ！”＃＄％＆’
弟）ｗｗｗｗｗｗ
ED）トゥントゥントゥントゥン…